well in the coffin white just steps with  the rook  takes control of an open line and all  that needs to be done  is move the white king into the action  and  black's position is just creaking i mean  is  any hope i don't see anything i mean  literally zero  i think at this point um yeah i think  white can just step forward with the  white king white can improve the white  rook  the white thing yep there we go white  stroke jumps into the position  we did mention black's bishop being  terrible it is defended by black's  knight right now it's not under  uh it's not under fire yet but if black  ever does get tempted to capture the  white knight then  white just establishes i mean i keep  using the word dominant but  establishes a dominant pawn and black  black will be completely paralyzed  uh roger bob just resigns wow wow  timor jabo he resigns the third game  against magnus carlsen  and i can kind of see magnus true you  wanted to smile there  winning the third game